we had a really tough night here on that
on the east coast and we're going to
begin with the extreme weather now being
slammed by what's left of hurricane ida
the system is currently over new england
after cutting a destructive path through
multiple states affecting at least
57 million people
here in new york the entire subway
system was shut down due to the flooding
take a look at these pictures and many
roads were inundated trapping drivers in
their cars at least nine people were
killed across the area new york and new
jersey declared states of emergency the
remnants of ida also spun off multiple
tornadoes including this one in bristol
pennsylvania mola lenghi is in middlesex
new jersey mola what are you seeing this
morning good morning
well good morning vlad yeah middlesex
new jersey we're nearby bound brook
flooded overnight creating this mess
that you see here behind me as you can
see the roads impassable authorities
have it
shut down nearby homes had to be
evacuated this morning and overnight but
really no matter where you were in the
northeast in the last 24 hours or so you
likely got clobbered by some sort of
severe weather between the flooding and
the tornado damage statistically in the
new york city area this type of rain
happens only once every 200 years
look at that tornado
a tornado tore through southern new
jersey wednesday possibly the strongest
to ever hit the state it ripped the
sides off some homes and turned others
into a pile of rubble
as the remnants of hurricane itis spun
off other possible twisters in
pennsylvania
the storm sent water pouring into new
york city subways forcing all trains to
stop oh my god
rain flooded the streets reaching some
car windows
the cars are floating
and lifting others right off the road
the national weather service issued a
flash flood emergency for the first time
ever in new york city
as strong winds blew rain sideways into
the covered us open stadium in queens
during a match forcing play to be
suspended
in brooklyn rescue crews worked to save
drivers trapped in the flood
and this biker found himself in
waist-deep water apparently trying to
deliver someone's dinner
meanwhile some buildings in manhattan
were no match for the flood
water rushing into this apartment parts
of the region got three inches of rain
in just an hour believed to be a record
in the area the destruction in the
northeast came after ida wreaked havoc
in parts of virginia and maryland
burying cars and mud and in the
annapolis area a tornado tore down power
lines leaving this tangled mess of trees
and wires
the nearby raritan river is expected to
get 14 feet above flood stage by
tomorrow but as far as the storm the
remnants of ida tony that appears to be
behind us well that is good news mole
thank you very much for more on the
storm's path we are joined now by cbs
news meteorologist and climate
specialist jeff beridelli jeff good
morning to you what are you looking at
good morning tony good morning everybody
if you were watching yesterday you heard
me say that this was a once in a century
event well it turns out by some
measurements it's a once in a 500 year
type event meaning that we should only
experience this once since our country's
founding that's how epic this was now
the system made its way across new
jersey pennsylvania new york city
connecticut producing rain rates up to
four inches an hour now the heavy rain's
about to exit southeast new england but
what's amazing about this system is it
produced all this heavy rainfall across
the gulf coast then a bit of a break and
then a tremendous amount of heavy rain
also in the northeast so what's going on
storm made landfall 17 inches of rain in
places along the gulf coast and then it
was supercharged again once it got to
the new york city area staten island
getting 13 to 14 inches of rain here's
one of the reasons tropical connection
of moisture you can see this tail of
moisture extending into the gulf into
the atlantic and all of it dumping right
on top of the new york city and
pennsylvania area and then number two
ida merged with a jet stream and a cold
front so it supercharged item and it
wrung out all the moisture all that
tropical moisture connection running out
right on top of new york city on top of
new jersey on top of the hudson valley
connecticut and now that system is
moving out to the east but the bottom
line here is that a supercharged storm
does obviously a lot more damage
remember it didn't do much along the way
and then all of a sudden it just kind of
came back to life so jeff
we talk about these storms as
once-in-a-century events or once in the
history of the country events and yet
they're happening more frequently it
sure seems like we're going to update
our numbers
for sure so you know what i like to say
is climate change makes the impossible
not only possible but it makes it
probable the bottom line is a warmer
atmosphere holds more moisture it's like
a bigger sponge that sponge can hold
more moisture and then it can wring out
even heavier rainfall so in the
northeast you can see the clear trend on
this graphic over the last 60 years
we've seen a 50 percent increase in
heaviest rain events in the new york
city area and all across new england and
you can see that clear trend when the
air is two degrees warmer which it is
right now it holds eight percent more
moisture but storms do a really good job
pulling all that extra moisture and kind
of congregating and kind of bolstering
that even more in harvey we saw 20 to 40
percent more rain than we would have
otherwise seen without climate change
and infrastructure and asphalt in the
new york city and houston area makes a
big difference i had to go to new jersey
last night for a funeral it was very
very very scary on the roads i signed
and this is just a you call it a remnant
this is what a remnant looks like this
is going to happen a lot more it's going
to get a lot worse in the future as we
keep warming the planets and as you say
gail a remnant and we're going to go to
louisiana now where they got the brunt
of it exactly jeff as always my friend
thank you very much